congratulations to
on being the the
singular reason for
the word viral video how about that like
it was and it wasn't even you that came
up with the word it was
was it the new york times um washington
post
washington post i think i don't know if
that's been validated but it's such a
good story that i
will just continue to tell it yeah i
mean
at the washington post in 2003
i think that was when the term viral
video was coined about
that video that my other band yeah
secret ipod's dirty secret about how
they had an
internal battery which they would refuse
to replace
so they their idea was okay cool our
battery dies after
18 months that was casey's experience
yeah and then people are gonna be
they're gonna be like man [ __ ] my
battery died they're gonna buy a new
ipod
casey took exception to that he said hey
uh replace my [ __ ] battery ed called
him up right and
they said ah now you're gonna buy a new
ipod yeah rub me the wrong way
yeah and um and this was
like he said 2003 two years before
youtube came out
and there were six million views
of his ipod video called ipod's dirty
secret
but what i want to know is how how are
those six million views tabulated
if the way that the video is uh
viral so to speak was just through email
yeah so like um we had a page counter
that would flip every time someone
clicked on the play
button on the quicktime okay you built
like the most basic splash page possible
i remember that
that makes perfect this is a single page
that had one video centered
and the you could click refresh and it
wouldn't move
the counter forward but if you click
play it would move the counter forward
you could juke that by watching it 10
times in a row right but like
whatever if our margins are still small
like that
it it had like a really big impact
socially like in the world so whatever
the number was it like that movie
really went kind of gangbusters that was
the first thing that my brother van and
i were ever kind of recognized for
sure it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your
butthole yeah
yeah dude